thing
yesterday the Canadian P3 detected
underwater noises in the search area
as a result ROV operations were
relocated in an attempt to explore the
origin of the noises
although the ROV searches have yielded
negative results they continue
Additionally the data from the P3
aircraft has been shared
with our U.S Navy experts for further
analysis which would be considered in
future search plans
the surface search is now approximately
two times the size of Connecticut and
the subsurface search is up to two and a
half miles deep
exponentially expanding the size of the
search area
we also have to factor in Ever Changing
weather conditions currents and sea
states that expand the search area every
hour
there's an enormous complexity
associated with this case due to
location being so offshore so far
offshore and the coordination between
multiple agencies and Nations
we greatly appreciate the outpouring of
support and offers to provide additional
equipment
the unified command continues to
prioritize assets and resources in order
to provide the best capability in the
most timely manner
this includes weighing multiple factors
to identify the most effective resources
available to the response operation
with careful consideration consideration
the timeliness of equipment arriving on
scene usefulness and ability to deliver
assets to the search area
over the past 48 hours we have through
incredible Unity of effort mobilized and
implemented a tremendous amount of
expertise and response capability
in addition to the ships and aircraft
previously mentioned we've dispatched
two subject matter experts from U.S Navy
navsea subsalve who will serve as search
coordinators on scene for underwater
search operations
so I've been stressing a Unity of effort
a lot in this statement and that's
because it is absolutely critical to
this complex operation
again our thoughts and prayers are with
the crew of the Titan and their loved
ones
we will continue to work as hard and as
quickly as possible in an effort to
locate them
I will take a few questions but before I
do that I do want to I'm going to have
each of the members the team here just
introduce themselves and then I'll go
ahead and take some questions
I'm Paul Hankins I'm the director for
Salvage operations with the U.S Navy's
supervisor of Salvage
hello I'm Carl Hartsfield from the Woods
Hole oceanographic Institute
uh good afternoon I'm Lieutenant
Commander Rich guntharia I'm an exchange
officer currently serving on the staff
of Commander submarines Atlantic at
Norfolk Virginia
lieutenant
compulsely with Captain Frederick from
RCC Boston search and rescue mission
coordinator thank you
so a couple things one I think when
you're in the middle of a search and
rescue case you always have hope that's
that's why we're doing what we do
um with respect to the noises
specifically
we don't know what they are to be frank
with you um we the the P3 detected
noises that's why they're up there
that's why they're doing what they're
doing that's why they put so in our
buoys in the water
um
the good news is what I can tell you is
we're searching in the area where the
noises were detected and we'll continue
to do so and we we hope
um that when we're able to get
additional rovs which will be there in
the morning the intent will be to
continue to search in those areas where
the noises were detected and if they're
continuing to be detected and then put
additional rovs down in the last known
position where the search was originally
taking place
I hadn't heard a 30-minute intervals so
here's what I can tell you we so
I I am not a trained here for underwater
Aquatics
um that's why we have a team of experts
that are analyzing that data that data
was sent immediately to uh to the Navy
uh last night and it was analyzed
overnight they're still looking at it
but I can tell you that it's it's
inconclusive but again I think the
important piece is we're searching in
the area where the noises were detected
it's a timeline of well respect
okay all right so
well
in terms of so we talked about the
action number I think you're all
tracking the action number I think
there's an important point with that
though the oxygen that that that's just
one piece of data right there there are
a lot of pieces of data that we need to
consider and
you know we're continuously looking at
that and we'll continuously uh you know
do that throughout the search um
but that's not the only thing that's
important right and right now our
efforts are are solely focused on the
search that certainly is a dialogue
that's happening
um but uh but we're focused on searching
at this point
oh this is a this is a search and rescue
mission 100 we are smack dab in the
middle of search and rescue and uh and
uh we'll continue to put every available
asset that we have in an effort to
define the Titan and the crew members
so a couple things so the rovs all each
ROV brings different capability uh the
rovs that are diving today
um but what's the what's the depth on
the third four thousand meters and the
some additional rovs that'll be arriving
tomorrow have additional depth
capability
um with respect to uh an object so
yesterday one of the aircraft did see an
object I will tell you this in search
and rescue missions when aircraft are
flying continuously there is stuff out
in the ocean that is floating
um we went back we looked at it it it
wasn't we didn't determine it to be
debris we don't think it's it correlates
with the case and it is not uncommon at
all during an active search to see
things and then we go and look at them
so
yeah so the P so several P3 flights are
have heard the noises
um as yesterday and we put uh assets
there uh we relocated assets immediately
um with respect to uh food and Waters my
understanding there are some limited
rations I I can't tell you exactly how
much
um they have a board but they do have
some limited rations aboard uh the
vessel
listen you I think you need to be
careful
um
we need to have hope right but but I
don't I can't tell you what the noises
are but what I can tell you is and I
think this is the most important point
we're searching where the noises are and
that's all we can do at this point
so I so I just wanted to so it was my
understanding that the P3 had heard some
noises today as well but so I do want to
take just an opportunity to uh to invite
uh Carl uh to the podium just to talk a
little bit about
um he has a little bit more expertise
and underwater
um Acoustics and maybe just to speak to
that in general because again
um you know there are noises below the
surface of the ocean
um and uh so I'll just turn it to Carl
uh yes uh c-a-r-l h-a-r-t-s-f-i-e-l-d
so again Carl Hartsfield from the Woods
Hole oceanographic institution uh so the
ocean is a very complex Place obviously
uh human sounds nature sounds and it's
very difficult to discern what the
source of those noises are at times but
I can't tell you that this team has
multiple sensors they're in the area
they're sending data back expeditiously
to the best in the world people to
analyze that data and then they're
feeding the results of that analyst back
to the unified team and they're making
decisions so Woods Hole is here in an
advisory role but uh by our expertise
what I see is a very tight operational
Loop that's making decisions based on
data and nothing is ruled out
because foreign
there have been multiple reports of
noises and every one of those noises is
being analyzed tracked look for patterns
and reported upon can you describe what
the noise can you describe what the
noise sounds like that they're hearing
uh well you know the noise is again very
complex in the ocean uh you have to be
an acoustic analysis and you have to
have context they're trying to put all
the pieces together the noises have been
described as banging noises but again
they have to put the whole picture
together in context and they have to
eliminate uh potential man-made sources
other than the Titan is it possible is
it possible that a ship in the ocean is
it possible a ship in the ocean or even
some mammals out there could mimic that
kind of sound so I can tell you from my
experience with Acoustics that there are
Sounds by biologics that sound man-made
to the untrained ear but I can assure
you that the people listening to these
tapes are trained there are a lot of
vessels in the area and they each make
noise right so all of that has to be
eliminated and its analysis over time
plus as the captain said it's we're the
team is searching in the right area so
if you continue to analysis do the
analysis look for
different patterns and search in the
right area uh you're uh you're doing uh
you know the best you possibly can do
with the best people on uh the case
that was sent there to the location can
you tell if it's if it's on site yet and
how it operates and how long it would
take the rest to wake up
which which uh system does he speaking
about do you know the system what's the
system that you're talking about
that's just the hydraulic yeah
a crane yeah so that's right so so that
that's a piece of equipment uh it's a
crane piece of equipment um there are a
lot of pieces of equipment flowing in
through St John's right now
um one thing I did want to mention I
think it's important
um
some of the ROV capability that's
arriving soon is is incred is is really
great incredible uh capability one thing
I want to point out is that French team
that's coming in
um to serve a board with their equipment
aboard a friendship uh they they bring
some state of the art equipment and um
so once they get on we're going to have
more assets down to look and we'll
continue to put them um where we think
the best location is
plus are you still
um
how many days is it just how many days
so
well so
we we have to remain optimistic and
hopeful when you're in a search and
rescue case
so we're in this we're right in the
middle of search rescue case so I I
don't I don't want to get into a
discussion about when that would end
with respect to this case what I will
tell you though I'm happy to to explain
to you kind of how that process were to
work
um you know
the Coast Guard prosecute search and
rescue cases on a daily basis and
sometimes we don't find what we're
looking for and you have to
you have to carefully consider uh all of
the factors and um there are a lot of
factors you consider
and then after you consider all those
factors sometimes you're you're in a
position where you have to make a tough
decision we're not there yet
um
but if we continue to search
potentially we could be at that point
but again we're not there yet and that's
a discussion that we will have with the
family long before I'm going to discuss
that here publicly operation look like
yeah so I can't put a number on on on
the like you know I'm not going to put a
percent I don't have a percentage number
what I would tell you is that that is
just one data point and there are more
there are more data points than that
that we have to look at so right now we
continue to search and we'll have that
later
sure
so the the report so
that
the the noises were heard by a Canadian
P3
and that was this morning and some
yesterday I don't know specifically over
that 30 minute intervals but again I
really think the important point to that
is
we're in the air we're searching there
we moved assets and we're searching
there and um and we'll continue to do so
yeah I don't so listen I
whether it's operable or whether it's
sitting on the ocean floor whether it's
in the C column whether it's in the
surface I you know I it's all
speculation and we're just we're just
not in the business of speculation we're
in the business of searching and we're
putting everything we can with the data
we have to search for The Vessel I think
we'll take uh we'll take one more
question
yeah so so we um
we we asked uh for some additional um
uh subsurface uh support and we got that
through the Navy
um through a liaison officer he's just
one of many team members and we're we're
greatly appreciative of the British
government and all the sport they've
given us
so uh I think the plan will be to do it
to do a daily like this I'm not gonna
it's a lock into that right now but um
but we'll keep you informed and
certainly if there's any major
developments to let you know thank you
very much